a key for bread in South hartum hungry
people hoping to take advantage of a
temporary ceasefire that's been extended
by the two warring sides some have been
waiting for many hours and worry they'll
go home empty-handed
I swear I have been here since three in
the morning so far I have not been able
to get one loaf of bread my children
have not eaten anything since yesterday
and today is almost gone
the UN is warning the humanitarian
crisis in Sudan is turning into what it
calls a full-blown catastrophe and
millions are affected
we are government employees and our
salaries have not been paid most of the
people are now re-prioritizing their
needs they're not even targeting 30
percent of their basic needs we pray
this crisis comes to an end and our
country restores peace and security
fuel in the capital is in short supply
most petrol stations are closed the few
that are open have long queues
there is relief for some who've been
unable to access their savings for more
than two weeks the Central Bank of Sudan
says most of its branches outside the
capital have reopened it's reassured
Savers that despite looting their
deposits are safe
so far we've not faced any problems
clients are handling their accounts cash
is flowing and people are buying and
selling the situation was difficult in
the early days of the conflict but now
everything is back to normal
people trapped in the areas of bakri and
East Nile north of the capital hartum A
bracing for more airstrikes and
explosions as the Army and the
paramilitary rapid support forces battle
for control of Sudan at the expense of
its people Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera
and Heather Morgan has more from
Khartoum
both sides the Sudanese Army and the
rapid support forces have placed
conditions for their envoys or their
delegates to talk to each other they
have not agreed to direct talks that's
the commander of the rapid support
forces and the Sudanese Army have not
agreed to a direct meeting but they did
say that they will be sending envoys to
meet each other but each site has a
condition the Sudanese Army wants the
talks to focus on a ceasefire and then
making sure that the rapid support
forces is no longer part of Sudan's
political or military institutions
meanwhile the rapid support forces has
the condition of a ceasefire on the
ground that is actually being
implemented before holding any talks
with the Sudanese Army and right now
that is not happening there have been
airstrikes in the city of soba in the
eastern part of the capital Khartoum and
this is just a continuation of repeated
airstrikes overnight around the vicinity
of the presidential Palace and in the
northern part of the capital fighting
has also been reported in the city of
umdurman with heavy artillery fire being
heard fired by the rapid support forces
surface-to-air missiles targeting the
fighter jets of the Sudanese Army and
this is when there's supposed to be a
ceasefire right now it's the second day
of a sixth sixth ceasefire that has been
agreed upon by both sides but on the
ground people say they're not seeing any
of it being manifested and based on that
it doesn't look like those two sides
will be meeting anytime soon with the
conditions that they set
you know how to motasa reports in the
refugee situation in neighboring South
Sudan
we're hearing a lot from people who
took to get here they say in Sudan they
had to go through several checkpoints
and the people managed these checkpoints
would charge each of them a certain
amount of money not in student needs
money in American dollars to pass when
they get to the border with South Sudan
it seems like those with money seem to
get out faster for example if they want
to get a private plane or a private bus
or truck they pay a lot of money to
board these vehicles to then reach tube
and other parts of the country but many
people don't have the money so thousands
of people are still stuck along the
border waiting for either the government
or Aid agencies try and reach them there
is some effort to get to these people
but the issue is of course the roads
aren't always good they're trying to get
as much transport as possible from buses
from barges to use the river or airplane
to try and airlift people out so it's a
long process the thousands are still
stuck there hearing Jew with the capital
people are also talking about the fear
of shortages they're saying that
remember South Sudan doesn't make much
so a lot of its products come from Sudan
so there's a fear that soon if this
crisis can continues they'll be sorted
to the fuel and other Foods so people
are worried about that and that's just
an example of how the crisis in Sudan is
affecting South Sudan and will
eventually if it's all the other
neighboring countries in the region